i don't want to be around the bush have
you heard of the save ima norway masjid
project your brothers and sisters at
islam that are establishing a one of his
kind masjid dawa and community center in
the capital of norway and they need our
urgent support now every person that
accepts islam through this center every
revert who learns about their deen and
calls their family to the worship of
allah you will get the rewards inshallah
click the button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the video
brothers and sisters and dear friends 15
countries have banned pixels i think toy
story yeah okay something all those
lines yeah i can't be bothered to even
know what the hell it is uh because from
what we know disney if i'm not mistaken
disney or one of these big companies in
hollywood uh have said that they are
aiming to have um all their characters
well 50 of them to be you know uh pro
lgb qt and so basically they're going to
be uh promoting this and it's very uh
amazing like it's if you think about it
bro and sisters they are literally
literally have an outright war like i
said before from the zebra crossings to
the burgers that we ate to even our
gayness well mayonnaise but it's gay
they have
that version as well and they're just
trying to put this down our front they
are trying to literally put it down our
sisters
literally brothers and sisters this
however is good in the context where
these 15 countries who are banning this
is going to have a financial impact on
them okay it's going to have a financial
impact on them and this is why it's so
profound that allah subhanahu ta'ala
mentions in the quran if i'm saying
i think it's
that when he when allah destroyed these
nations for their transgression that the
one of the prophets
he said do not
do not let one of them survive
destroy them
completely this is by god yeah god
almighty okay god uh punishing his
creation why
because he knows
god almighty knew i know allah knew that
if you used to let one of them
they will not stop okay they will not
stop their transgression they would
carry on okay that's the reason why we
believe that in our religion that god
almighty destroyed some nations and
literally got wiped them all out why
because he knows the transgression
that's not going to stop they will never
leave us alone i mean the thing is it's
come to a point where people are scared
to say they're heterosexual they are
scared to say the heterosexual i mean
should we start a movement subhanallah
saying that you know be proud to be
straight and you can see
that this is going to enter every single
household i urge families parents who
are listening to this watching this
please please vet the cartoons very very
carefully i'm telling you this is an
outright war and we need to make sure
that we intellectually academically and
with all our power and might oppose this
based on our beliefs and it does not
make us homophobic neither does it make
someone islamophobic if they disagree
with our versions of what we believe the
sin of homosexuality is so we are here
to and we have every damn right to
defend our right for our children to be
brought up the way we believe is best
which is god almighty's laws which is
objective morality not subjective that
changes every two seconds and we see
those contradictions with this very
movement when it comes to incest love
when it comes to love there is a there's
a condition now no now you can't love
there is no love is love no love is not
love anymore now we can see these
contradictions brothers and sisters and
who knows there might come a time they
would even have no problem with incest
and that's exactly what's happening with
sisters and we
and we hope
more christian countries the follow this
well if there's any christian countries
left that follow this and ban this move
so that we can show them enough is
enough if you want to be homosexual be
homosexual do not bring it to us
okay do not bring it to us do not force
us because we will never submit we only
submit to the one that's created us till
the day we die inshallah and we salute
those 15 countries and many more who
that there will ban this inshallah and
this is why allah says in the quran if
you forget my remembrance i will make
you forget your own self
and that's exactly what we're living
wrong sisters people have forgotten
their own selves they are doing nothing
but following their desires and like
allah says have you seen the one who
follows his desires as his own god that
is exactly what they're doing
brothers and sisters be patient indeed
this life is a test and in the hereafter
wallahi true success is with the
believers inshallah and may allah
protect our kids and children from this
filthy fitnah and inshallah um allow us
to nurture nurture them inshallah in the
way god has prescribed us till next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh
i don't want to be around the bush have
you heard of the savimah norway masjid
project your brothers and sisters at
islam that are establishing a one of his
kind masjid tawa and community center in
the capital of norway and they need our
urgent support now every person that
accepts islam through this center every
revert who learns about their deen and
calls their family to the worship of
allah you will get the rewards inshallah
click the button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the video